bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy vamos a recordar algunos
apartes inolvidables en la vida del
futbolista fallecido diego armando
maradona el nápoles fue el club del
calcio italiano con el cual maradona
demostró que era el por entonces mejor
jugador de fútbol del mundo
nápoles fue esa ciudad del sur de italia
que acogió con un inmenso fervor la
llegada del astro argentino maradona
venía de haber jugado 2 años con el
barcelona donde pese a las grandes
expectativas no pudo brillar por su
fútbol durante los cortos dos años en el
club catalán tuvo fuertes peleas con
jugadores árbitros y técnicos que le
valieron lesiones expulsiones y
sanciones agotadas las directivas del
barcelona decidieron en 1984 ceder al
nápoles el pase de maradona por 7.5
millones de euros un equipo modesto que
hasta la fecha no había ganado nada
importante en su historia parecía el
final de maradona
el nápoles era un club
sin palmarés sin prestigio internacional
pero particularmente fue el club en el
cual maradona potenciaría su lucha
social según el cineasta emir kusturica
si maradona no hubiera sido futbolista
habría sido revolucionario no por azar
tenía tatuado a fidel castro en su
pierna y al ché guevara ha sido brazo
amaba la cuba de fidel despotricaba de
bus en eeuu y apoyaba a los gobiernos de
izquierda latinoamericanos en argentina
prefirió jugar en el boca juniors antes
que en el river plate que pagaba más en
cuanto al nápoles
maradona sentenció ante la prensa que en
italia no había un racismo por el color
de piel sino el ejercido por los ricos
del norte contra los pobres del sur en
los años 80 el fútbol italiano era de
los más importantes del mundo pero los
equipos que siempre figuraban eran los
del norte del país la juventus el milán
el inter el torino cuando maradona
públicamente resarció al nápoles de una
presunta discriminación del norte del
país la ciudad se agolpó a tomarlo por
héroe
romance entre el club y el astro se
consagró en noviembre de 1985 cuando por
un gol aparentemente imposible de hacer
maradona sentenció a la juventus de
michel platini se trataba del equipo más
poderoso de italia y uno de los más
importantes de europa al ganarle por ese
tanto de maradona en una cancha mojada y
con barro el estadio san paolo se volvió
loco hilarante mientras maradona hacía
soñar a los napolitanos con que su
equipo llegara a la cima del fútbol
italiano en mexico comenzaba la copa
mundo de 1986 luego de haber superado la
primera ronda de partidos llegaría el
encuentro más icónico y recordado en la
historia de maradona como futbolista
argentina se medía contra inglaterra en
el estadio azteca de ciudad de mexico
este partido cargaba un enorme
simbolismo hacía cuatro años que la
inglaterra en margaret thatcher había
derrotado aplastantemente en una guerra
a los argentinos en las islas de las
malvinas de manera que maradona función
en aquel partido como un nuevo
se trataba de una revancha así que en el
minuto 51 del partido anotó un
controvertido gol luego de disfrutar en
el aire una pelota con el arquero inglés
peter shilton e impactar la pelota con
su puño izquierdo haciendo creer que
había sido un golpe de cabeza
aquel tanto quedó bautizado como la mano
de dios' luego de que maradona dijera
que no era él quien la había tocado sino
el propio dios el segundo gol que
maradona convirtió en aquel encuentro
fue catalogado años después como el gol
del siglo en referencia al mejor gol en
la historia de los mundiales
maradona se adueñó del balón desde su
propia cancha
rápidamente emprendió camino hacia la
cancha rival eludiendo a cinco jugadores
para finalmente burlar al portero y
marcar agónicamente un tanto histórico
[Aplausos]
con la victoria 2 a 1 sobre inglaterra
argentina paso a semifinales en donde
venció a bélgica para luego coronarse
campeona al vencer a la república de
alemania federal
viniendo de ser el campeón del mundo
maradona se había convertido en una
celebridad mundial los napolitanos
creían tener en su ciudad al mejor
jugador de fútbol del planeta y sus
esperanzas estaban puestas en que el
nápoles lograra resultar campeón de la
liga italiana el 10 de mayo de 1987 con
más de 90.000 almas clamando la hazaña
de su equipo maradona función como el
glorioso héroe de aquella ciudad del sur
de italia nápoles había logrado el
primer scudetto de sesión
tres años después en 1990 el nápoles que
también había fichado el brasileño
careca ganó un segundo scudetto y la
supercopa de italia en síntesis durante
los siete años de maradona en el nápoles
el equipo ganó dos scudettos o ligas una
copa y una supercopa de italia y la copa
de la uefa un palmarés que catapultó a
maradona en la cima de los más grandes
su gloria en el nápoles no pudo
repetirse con la camiseta de su
selección luego de la derrota de
argentina ante los alemanes en la final
de la copa mundo de italia 90 con
lágrimas de frustración
maradona comenzaba una década de los 90
mucho menos prometedora que la de los 80
el consumo excesivo de drogas las
fiestas y los escándalos personales
empañaron una parte de su vida en 1991
ante una prueba de antidoping fue
sancionado por la fifa a 15 meses por
fuera de las canchas y así maradona
salió por la puerta de atrás del nápoles
sin siquiera despedirse sin embargo el
nápoles y los napolitanos lo perdonaron
el corazón de la ciudad quedó la gloria
de aquellos siete años desde entonces
nápoles fue maradona y maradona también
fue el nápoles así llegamos al final soy
andrés suárez jaramillo gracias por
compartir estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]